hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the second annual Karen's Cup we are
in the midst of a thrilling round four
but we have a very special guest yes
yes we do in fact that's right so you
have dr. Jeanne sing filled with
Alejandra Ramirez of course without her
this tournament just wouldn't be
possible Jeanie welcome to the show of
your own events yeah Jeanne Karen
Sinquefield she carries a field that's
why we're here toss how have you enjoyed
the tournament so far lots of fun lots
of wins yes not yeah I think the women's
justice it compares it's like you know
if you watch college basketball or you
watch the pros college basketball is
more fun I think the women's tournaments
are more fun well there you go I mean
we've had a lot of fun doing the
commentary here in this event so far
thoughts of other players anybody that a
strike us like that's a very interesting
one they're there they're very different
that's very true
do you know they're coming from I know
five different six different countries
and you know they're not making a lot of
money as being chess players and they
just stuck was it never serious you know
keep on that you sort of think it's like
I don't know maybe if I got a you know
bottle of wine and we conversation this
character would change you know yeah
sometimes you see them whole series and
business they're on the chess board Bart
very different personality certainly
often we got to see them a little bit
when we go out to dinner here around the
chess club or just see them in
interviews yeah life changes and they
become a little different you know
certainly do we off the board on the
board completely different people tell
us about some of the other projects that
you've been working on one of them you
must be especially proud of yeah I bet I
well last last year I finished my learn
to read and write chess that was it's a
workbook for kids I think like I had a
seven-year-old use it to teach her and
we see it on the screen right here
Oh five-year-old things and now what's
interesting is being district it's
available for free
it's on the US chess trust site Nathan
grow edit our site and it's being used
as senior centers where seniors are
learning how to read and write chess
that's absolutely wonderful timing is
being translated through several
different languages yeah yeah sirs wife
you bet not Yasser have the skill set
okay
translated it into Dutch okay I just
finished translating it into Indonesian
so I'm going to be sending it to the
Indonesian Chess Federation to get them
I I haven't published an Indonesian for
like very long number of years so I need
someone to you know make sure that I'm
using current language but you're a
published author an Indonesian yeah
Indonesian French Spanish so I'm gonna
work on the Spanish next - I'll be
working and although the original
translation and Alejandro will read it
laughs and go nobody says it that way
I'm sure it'll be just minor details and
thoughts more about the Boy Scouts
activities personally the boys called
badge that well was basically all you're
doing yeah it's getting closer 250,000
Scouts netting curl her and Kurt include
last year starting in February the Boy
Scouts allowed girls to form their
separate sexes troops so they last year
were the first girls in America and the
chest merit badge and and the club did
that
a member of the commentary staff and
they're going to be teaching it again in
was it Thursday yeah yes Thursday so yes
and then I've been working with
hall-of-fame we have a plans for a
do-it-yourself large chess pieces yeah
so that you can print them out either on
cardboard or use a CNC router or carve
them out for wood well we just got to
make the plans free so you could make it
so you maybe you can't afford $800
plastic large stuff but this will be
sized for like a 1 foot square board
okay it's still pretty sizable big
enough right of course then you can add
color to them you know or decorations
you know you see the fancy chess stuff
at the club
people have decorated chess sets yes
well you know I have some people down at
my farm who want to do it do it in cameo
they're gonna do red and white and black
and white oh well I'll have to see those
but it's an amazing outreach 250000 I
mean you must be so proud of this
project yeah and if you go there are a
lot of boy scout camps now like the one
down to Lake of the Ozarks they have two
big chess sets I'm gonna actually be
teaching chess it's a merit badge two
three troops that are coming down my
farm and a couple of weeks all-girl
troops all girls our troops and other
female empowerment is great here so many
projects going around can't wait for
Wednesday we'll have a lot of young
ladies here willing to not only learn
but teach chess and I think that's a
great way to get the game out there well
Judy just to let you go one more
question if you have to change something
about this sort of and what would it be
maybe not have it in February it is
Valentine's Day we are full of romance
in the air but it is cold in st. Louis
yeah I don't think the Russians are
minding that much because it is warmer
here then in Moscow but I think some of
the other players might agree with you
well thank you so much for all you do
here at the segment stress web and
sincerely the outreach for chats in just
so many different ways thank you Jeannie
Singh field
[Music]